You know, I started talking to Marvel
about developing something else.
I remember Kevin saying to me, like,
we really should think about in an actual Agatha show.
And I was like, Where do I sign for that job?
we had early conversations about, you know,
what could that be?
And maybe it's this property
and maybe it's this property
And everything that I pitched
included a storyline about Agatha.
and continuing the story of Agatha
and getting to know her more was immediately
an imperative for us as Yeah, we got they got it.
The character is so deep and heartfelt and dangerous
The whole thing made total sense to me,
and I was just so excited and thrilled.
There would be nothing more delicious
to Agatha Harkness than to be in a spin off.
To be playing a witch in the MCU is
amazing love you guys so much.
Welcome back, everyone.
Is Charlie Marvel dropped a potato quality version
of their Agatha Darkhold Diaries teaser trailer.
There's a bunch of Scarlet Witch stuff
going on during this because it is a wandavision spin
off is Scarlet Witch is coming back in the MCU
so we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
I will do episode videos for when it does
release next year and Halloween.
The reason why Marvel released
this is because it's actually
part of the Blu ray for Wandavision,
which they're releasing this week.
I'll give away a couple of copies.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber.
You just let me know what you want them to do
with Scarlet Witch in the future of
The MCU
I know a lot of you are hoping for some Scarlet Witch
X-Men crossovers like just crossover with Magneto.
Like try to tie these characters together.
We're like MCU version of Quicksilver
in some way, like bring Evan Peters back.
they got all the pieces.
They're like, It's all ready to go.
All right.
You look like Aaron Taylor-Johnson right now,
I literally just did a wandavision
Quicksilver deleted scene video explaining
what happened to him after the events of Wandavision.
So I'll link it at the end of this.
But there's a whole bunch of new footage
here in this teaser trailer.
They haven't finished the special effects yet
because it doesn't come out till next year.
That's why it looks a little bit weird.
the whole idea is
this is a much darker spin, like a much darker show
just because it's all about witches magic in the MCU.
So it is very appropriate
that they're releasing it around Halloween next year.
outside of the brand new footage,
most of the details that we have about
the series actually comes from Patti LuPone,
who you see in some of the footage.
Your funny.
No, because she totally doesn't give a crap
about her India contract.
So thank you to her for revealing all this information
She's not supposed to reveal.
she's actually playing.
Lily called Drew,
a descendant of the actual Cagliostro inside the MCU,
who's tasked with keeping the book of Kaggle, the Astro
that they featured in the first Doctor Strange movie
she's meant to be a descendant
of the first Baron Mordo,
not the main burn Mordo that we see in the Doctor.
Strange movies,
but his ancestor, the book she's tasked with keeping in
the comics is actually the book that Kaicilius
used to contact Dormammu and reach the Dark dimension.
It's also the same book
The Doctor Strange is reading from here
when he's using the time Stone as you would expect,
because it takes place mostly in Westview
when they're not traveling to other dimensions.
A lot of the characters from one division
are coming back.
the a lot of familiar faces inside the teaser trailer.
And yes, they do all remember
what happened with the Hex and Scarlet
Witch like they remember
that they were all held hostage for a while.
but just starting with the big stuff during this.
So there's footage of them all across West.
You like you see a bunch of different scenes
with them in people's homes across Westview.
but it's meant to pick up after Agatha breaks
scarlet witches spell and the reason why she breaks
the spell is because of her disappearance
at the end of Doctor Strange multiverse of madness.
Basically her chaos magic
that was keeping Agatha trapped inside her sitcom.
Reality breaks.
when Agatha told Scarlet Witch,
you're going to need me for what's coming,
you don't have any idea what you've unleashed.
She's talking about the threat that's coming
during the events of the Agatha Coven of Chaos series.
And it's going to be the Salem seven
Coven from the comics.
There was actually a deleted scene
that sort of explains what her prison is
like at the end of that series. are you injured?
No, I'm not handsome, but I could always use some mouth
to mouth.
funny thing about that,
the reason why she gets a laugh track
is because she's literally trapped
in a sitcom reality in that sitcom persona,
but only she can hear the laugh tracks.
So that's why none of the other FBI agents here
think that it's weird.
Like nobody's commenting that there is a laugh track.
it's meant to be kind of the same thing
she did the Scarlet Witch during the Wandavision series
when she was gaslighting her like Scarlet Witch,
sort of believing that she was in a sitcom,
listening to people off camera, talking to her
like you're not supposed to be able to talk to me.
that was both of them
using their magic to manipulate reality in that way.
But the whole idea is a scarlet witch's
disappearance at the end of Doctor Strange
multiverse of madness is what sets the plot off.
we don't have a full synopsis yet.
But we do know that Joe Locke is playing
Scarlet Witch's son Billy in adult form.
Like he'll become a version of Wiccan.
They're changing a little of Wilkins
comic book origin in the comics.
Obviously, Scarlet Witch
gave birth to her two children with vision.
But they were revealed to be small shards of Mephisto
who eventually reabsorbed them in the MCU.
Billy and Tommy were created by Scarlet Witch
using her chaos magic while inside the hex.
And after she brought the hex down, they disappeared.
knowing the comics much later, there's a very
twisty explanation for how Billy and Tommy come back
The way they explain them coming back,
still being Scarlet Witch's children
is that their souls are reincarnated
into the bodies of Billy Kaplan
in Tommy, in different families,
in different parts of the United States.
So they eventually joined the young Avengers.
They learned that they're related like, we're brothers.
And they learned that Scarlet
Witch is their true mother.
that all played out during the young Avengers
children's crusade comic book
the way they're changing that reincarnation
storyline in the MCU is supposedly saying that
Billy's soul is reincarnated into a recently deceased
teenager's body who just looks like Joe Locke
So that's why he winds up being older
and why he doesn't look like Scarlet Witch.
he continues to have all the same powers
that he had before.
He's meant to have about the same abilities
as Scarlet Witch, but because his power levels
are off the charts, another coven of witches
wants to use him to their own ends I don't know
if they're trying to use him to bring their master
into the main MCU dimension or something similar.
Either way, they want him.
opposed to all them.
If this no means I can't believe
we're all the way back at this Mephisto stuff again.
during the series, Agatha,
who's going to be more of an anti-hero
as opposed to the villain
that she was during Wandavision, although I would argue
that Scarlet Witch was doing stuff
that was just as bad.
So they were both doing a lot of shady stuff.
But Agatha tries to work against this rogue coven
trying to save Billy from the other witches
led by Aubrey Plaza.
Who's playing Rio Vidal?
She's not from the comics.
They just created her for the show.
This is her just off screen talking to Agatha.
during the series,
she's meant to be one of the most powerful magic users
and one of the oldest people in the MCU
next to Goddess stories.
Loki. So she's meant to be really, really powerful.
Patti LuPone. The other witches are part of her coven.
this place where they're all walking
is really important in the MCU.
It's going to be the version of The Witches Road,
which is a place
where Scarlet Witch is Body went during the Doctor
Strange Multiverse of Madness ending.
It's a big place in the comics
that only witches can go.
It's kind of like a holy place for them.
they kind of explained this
during the Moon Night series about how when you die,
your consciousness travels to other dimensions
based on your beliefs system.
The Witches Road is that place for Scarlet Witch.
This flash here was her chaos
magic, saving her, her body, acting on instinct,
transporting her consciousness
to this alternate dimension.
the funny thing though, zoom and enhance.
You can actually see Debra Jo Rupp's Mrs.
Hart character is with them.
So for whatever reason, who knows?
She follows them into the witch's road like,
let's just take a trip into this alternate dimension.
Just follow the yellow brick road.
So to speak.
zoom and enhance again
though notice that they're all barefoot.
The reason why they're not wearing shoes
is because they took them off as a sign of respect.
When they're in this alternate dimension.
like I said, it's meant to be a holy place
for witch breed and magic users
but even those Scarlet Witch's
soul is meant to be in this place.
And she's an important part of the plot.
I don't expect a ton of Elizabeth Olsen
cameos during the series.
I think the idea is that Joe Locke's Wiccan learns
that she's still alive, and at the end of the series,
we'll just come up with a plan to save her soul
and bring her back to the main MCU dimension.
I don't expect her to come back for real
until Avengers five,
but they might do some sort of spinoff with adult
Wiccan like a children's crusade type of storyline
and they might address her coming back
during that the only other place I know right now
that Wiccan would come back
for would be for young Avengers that they tease
at the end of the Marvel's movie with Ms..
Marvel and Kate Bishop,
like he and Tommy would come back for that.
the producer talking during this year is Jac Schaeffer.
She's the showrunner.
She was also the showrunner on Wandavision.
she's got three Marvel projects on her contract
Wandavision in this Agatha show or the first two.
So the third project might be a Scarlet Witch movie,
or like another spinoff with adult Wiccan.
there has been talk about them doing a Scarlet
Witch movie, but we'll see if that winds up happening.
I knew they had plans for Scarlet Witch in the future.
The MCU, a lot of X-Men related plans to.
We will see Elizabeth Olsen come back during
what if season two though
she'll be voicing her character during those episodes.
She was featured during the trailer.
It's sort of like a Merlin
ancient version of the character.
I think that she appears during the 1602 episodes.
looking at the footage.
You noticed a couple other details here too,
like the working title of the show on the Slates.
Here is my pretty
just making more puns about witches, luring people
into their gingerbread houses,
Notice Agatha has several costumes during the series.
This is similar to her eighties outfit
from the eighties episode.
Not sure who the dead body is, though.
You can let me know in the comments
like Why is Agatha in the morgue here?
Who died?
even though the show is meant to be its own thing,
they're kind of continuing
some of the themes of the Wandavision show.
Like she'll have a couple songs during the series like
Agatha all along this is her more traditional costume.
Notice.
She's wearing her brooch again
that she wore all through Wandavision.
I think the three figures are a representation
of the Hecate, the Greek goddess of witchcraft,
which has three different forms
the maiden, the mother and the crown.
It's meant to be a representation of eternal
youth and magic.
It might also be a representation
of the three Greek fates
and it might also be a reference
to the Wiccan rule of three.
The rule of three also called the threefold law
or the Law of Return, is a religious tenant held
by Wiccans.
Neo pagans in occult is they just states that
whatever energy a person puts out in the world
whether it be positive or negative,
will be returned to that person three times.
there's a whole bunch of footage going on here.
So there's any questions you have or any Easter eggs
you noticed that he didn't talk about in the video?
Just write them below in the comments.
We'll get a much more formal trailer
the next couple of months.
Congratulations on Envoy Eli in Brad 1980.
You're the giveaway winners
from my last big Marvel video.
Please email me on the about page of my channel
so I can get your contact details.
Everyone click here for that Wandavision Quicksilver
deleted scene an alternate ending and click here
for my Loki Season 2 Alternate
ending with a totally different beyond version of Loki
Thank you so much for watching
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!